[Music]
Ryan Reynolds reveals a hilarious family
secret while trying to get details out
of wife Blake Lively
it's show time the Deadpool star took to
Twitter on Saturday to Acosta's wife for
movie spoilers after she tweeted this
teaser trailer for her upcoming thriller
a simple favor I met Emily a few weeks
ago she is this wonderful elegant person
Blake plays Emily Nelson a mysterious
wealthy woman who befriends a mommy
blogger played by Anna Kendrick and Ryan
wants to know what happens to her
character I know your secret tell me the
41 year old actor retweeted the teaser
trailer along with this message quote
you can tell me we're married
he once drove me to the hospital when
you were giving birth so what the
happened Emily Blake and Ryan are
notorious for teasing each other on
social media she really does just show
me how to be better in almost every way
the 30 year old actress recently poked
fun at her homies the long-running
bromance with fellow Marvel star Hugh
Jackman after he instagrammed this photo
of them posing it as blake commented
quote is the extra distance between you
supposed to convince me that you don't
love him more than me nice try
[Music]
[Applause]